c'est bon
il y a merci
mesdames messieurs les journalistes pour
votre présence
à ce point presque nous voulions tenir
avec vous
les deux présidents de groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
Olivier Marleix et Bruno Retailleau pour
vous présenter le plan des républicains
pour rétablir l'ordre républicain en
France suite aux événements dramatiques
qui se sont installés dans notre pays
depuis la semaine dernière
elles peuvent se résumer en quelque
chiffres
12000 véhicules brûlés 10
000 commerces vandalisés
2500 bâtiments publics et privés
incendiés ou dégradé
dont plus d'une centaine de mairies
et 235 écoles
269 commissariats aux gendarmerie
incendiées ou dégradé
les estimations de ces dégradations
s'élèvent aujourd'hui à plus d'un
milliard d'euros et c'est une estimation
sommaire un milliard d'euros de dégâts
occasionnés un bilan lourd très lourd
plus lourd que celui des événements
similaires mais de plus faible ampleur
que nous avions connu en 2005
mais c'est nuit des nains d'émeutes au
delà de ces dégâts
bâtimentaires très lourd
ce sont aussi
800 membres des forces de l'ordre
policiers gendarmes pompiers blessés
alors qu'il faisait barrage à une forme
de barbarie
à nouveau
en 7 occasion je veux leur exprimer ma
plus profonde reconnaissance mon entière
gratitude et notre infini reconnaissance
sans eux la République n'aurait pas tenu
ils ont été le garant de la défense de
nos libertés et ils ont été les piliers
de la défense de nos institutions
au-delà des mots et des discours que
l'on entend depuis quelques jours
au-delà des rencontres des débats des
Grenelles habituels
qui se répètent sans fin et de façon
inlassable
nous nous ce que nous voulons nous
voulons désormais que nous passions à
l'action que la République que l'État
que le gouvernement passe à l'action
agir et passer à l'action face au
délitement de l'autorité
source de temps de désordre dans notre
pays
l'ordre a été courageusement défendu
désormais l'ordre doit être solidement
établi
face au chaos
nous avons soutenu l'action de l'État
nous avons soutenu l'action des
policiers des gendarmes des forces de
l'ordre et donc de ce qu'il est dirigé
et donc du ministre de l'intérieur nous
l'avons fait dans un esprit de
responsabilité dans un instant de
gravité pour la nation
toute polémique aurait été insensée au
milieu d'une véritable guérilla urbaine
mais aujourd'hui alors que notre pays a
retrouvé
un peu de calme
sans doute précaire l'heure est aux
conclusion et surtout à l'action
nous avons le devoir l'objectif
inlassable de garantir la paix civile à
l'intérieur mais aussi
à l'extérieur de nos frontières nous
avons le devoir de relever l'image
internationale de notre pays
elle est aujourd'hui atteinte dégradée
abîmée en mars dernier la France a été
contrainte d'annuler la visite d'État du
Roi Charles III la semaine dernière le
président de la République a été
contraint d'annuler sa visite en
Allemagne nous ne pouvons accepter
tolérer cette dégradation continue de
notre image dans le monde
pour que les scènes de pillage et de
saccage
auxquels nous avons assisté ne se
reproduisent plus nous devons rompre
avec
l'impuissance de l'immobilisme
les Français attendent exigent réclament
aujourd'hui et quelquefois avec une
colère légitime une volonté ferme de la
part de leur responsable politique face
aux désordre
il n'attendent plus je le redis une
énième stratégie de communication mais
des mesures efficaces claires sérieuse
responsable
les républicains portent cette exigence
et ils l'ont toujours porté et c'est ce
qui fait la différence avec la plupart
des formations politiques
nos propositions et nous voulons
aujourd'hui sont prêtes
nos textes de loi sont prêts certains
ont d'ores et déjà été déposées je pense
à ce concernant l'immigration qui est un
sujet majeur dans les causes qui se sont
exprimés qui expliquent ce qui s'est
déroulé dans notre pays nous avons
déposé des lundis après-midi les textes
pourtant
des réponses en matière de
responsabilité parentale nous déposerons
ce que nous développerons dans quelques
instants avec Bruno Retailleau et
Olivier Marleix les autres textes dans
les jours qui viennent tout à la fois
comme nous l'avons fait sur
l'immigration à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat nous devons nous attaquer
avec détermination à toute les causes
qui nous ont menées à cette situation
gravissime
nous devons nous attaquer à
l'immigration de masse qui déstabilise
trop nos territoires
nous avons déjà formulé des propositions
fortes en la matière nous y reviendrons
nous devons nous attaquer à la question
de l'insuffisance de la réponse pénale
insuffisance apporter aux violences
mais aussi insuffisance de la réponse
pénale face à la violence du quotidien
des Français tous les jours et pas
simplement par rapport à ce qui s'est
déroulé la semaine dernière
Pascal écrivait la justice sans la force
est impuissance la force sans la justice
est tyrannique
cette pensée doit en permanence nous
guider il est urgent de mettre fin à
cette impuissance qui nourrit l'impunité
nous proposerons dans nos textes
l'accroissement et la diversification de
notre capacité carcérale avec un
objectif de 80 000 places de prison à
l'horizon 2027
nous devons aussi quasiment doublé le
nombre de nos centres éducatifs fermés
cela nous permettra de connaître enfin
une véritable application des peines et
notamment des courtes peines de prison
que l'on a inopportunément supprimé
nous devons aussi armer la justice afin
qu'elle puisse répondre efficacement à
la délinquance des mineurs
un tiers des émeutiers interpellés au
moins de 10 ans le plus jeune
le ministre de l'Intérieur le soulignait
hier au Sénat a eu avait 10 ans cette
situation est insupportable
incompréhensible intolérable
nous devons pleinement rendre
responsable de leurs actes les jeunes
âgés de plus de 16 ans un abaissant la
majorité pénale et pour tout mineur qui
atteint qui attendent à l'ordre public
la comparution immédiate doit être la
règle comme elle est pour les adultes la
culture de l'excuse de l'impunité doit
être interrompue une autre cause des
désordres que nous avons connu se trouve
dans la déresponsabilisation des parents
dont beaucoup sont devenus
irresponsables dans tous les sens du
terme nous devons impérativement
rappeler aux parents
toutes les tendues de leur
responsabilité et surtout de leur devoir
l'article
371-1 du Code civil qui est lu dans tout
mariage prononcé dans nos mairies
le rappel clairement l'autorité
parentale est un ensemble de droits et
de devoirs ayant pour finalité l'intérêt
de l'enfant la responsabilité des
parents sera donc renforcée dans le
suivi des obligations judiciaires de
leurs enfants mais aussi concernant
l'absentéisme scolaire tout manquement
assez responsabilités parentales mènera
à la perte des allocations familiales
enfin il faut nous attaquer au
délitement de l'école et tout
particulièrement au délitement de
l'autorité au sein de nos écoles l'école
doit redevenir un sanctuaire ou l'ordre
la discipline et la citoyenneté reste
demeure revienne
oserais-je dire et des valeurs
cardinales
l'état
mesdames messieurs doit apporter une
réponse à la hauteur du chaos que nous
avons traversé
tout tièdeur sera perçu comme de la
faiblesse et ne pourra que nourrir
encore plus le désordre l'État doit se
tenir résolument et fidèlement
aux côtés des collectivités locales
chers Bruno et des élus qui ont payé un
lourd tribu dans ces combats qui ont
porté au plus haut point l'inquiétude ne
concitoyens ils sont chaque jour en
première ligne face à toutes les crises
qui nous frappent l'État doit les
protéger et les accompagner sans faiblir
avec l'ensemble de ces mesures que je
dont je dévoilerai le détail ensemble
dans quelques instants nous voulons
rétablir nous pouvons rétablir on en est
convaincu l'ordre en restaurant la
fermeté dans l'exercice de la justice la
responsabilité dans les familles et
l'autorité à l'école
en rétablissant l'ordre nous ne faisons
pas seulement acte de répression bien
au-delà nous défendons la liberté car il
n'y a pas de société libre dans le
désordre nous l'avons vu au cours de
toutes ces nuits des meutes le désordre
c'est toujours la loi du plus fort alors
face à cette loi de la violence qui veut
s'imposer partout
réaffirmons tout simplement avec
détermination la loi de la République
bien ce que je veux redire après Éric
c'est que
aucune mort tragique dramatique
ne peut servir de prétexte
et dans les moments que nous avons vécu
je crois que on s'est imposé une ligne
de conduite qui nous paraissait évidente
une ligne de responsabilité pour laisser
le gouvernement travailler
une ligne très clairement de soutien
aussi bien aux forces de l'ordre
policier nationaux municipaux
sapeurs-pompiers mais aussi les élus qui
sont en première ligne et on l'a vu
parfois au risque de leur propre vie
et puis
au-delà dès lors que l'ordre républicain
commence à être rétabli il faut se
projeter dans l'avenir et ça c'est le
deuxième temps le deuxième temps où il
faudra que le gouvernement ouvre grand
les yeux
je pense pour ma part que cette
embrasement est un tournant cette
embrasement est un tournée rien ne
serait pire que de faire comme à
l'habitude attendre que les choses
disparaissent des manchettes des
quotidiens des différents médias pour
vaquer aux occupations habituelles
traiter la question en déversant une
pluie de milliards ça les Français ne le
supportent plus ils ne le supportent
plus et donc il faut aller aux causes
racines
je pense que ces propositions nous le
faisons dans un état d'esprit très
précis
d'abord quand je parle de cause racine
c'est de dire de réaffirmer
que ce qui va convenir de reconstruire
ça n'est pas ce qui a brûlé pendant ces
nuits de chaos et de violence c'est
aussi ce qu'il faudra reconstruire tout
ce qui a été déconstruit pendant des
années et des années là se trouve
les racines du mal bien sûr l'école qui
ne se transmet plus à la fois ni savoir
suffisamment ni valeur républicaine
bien sûr l'autorité parentale on vient
d'en parler
bien sûr une réponse pénale vis-à-vis
des mineurs qui est aujourd'hui
totalement mais totalement inadapté on
vous parlera tout à l'heure de majorité
pénale bien sûr mais surtout
comparution directe courte peine etc
et puis enfin bien évidemment
l'immigration que le gouvernement se
cachent les yeux pour évacuer cette
question montre que il est toujours dans
le déni or
il faudra sortir du déni pour pouvoir
relever ces défis si demain
si demain on veut apaiser et traiter ce
qui a éclaté à la phase de tous les
Français et ce qui les a effectivement
sidéré
deuxième état d'esprit si j'ose dire ou
plutôt 2e disposition dans cet état
d'esprit c'est que un peu comme nous
l'avons fait avec le texte sur
l'immigration nous voulons soumettre
les propositions macronistes à l'épreuve
de vérité par rapport à nos propositions
parce que comme moi vous avez entendu
des déclarations cette idée par exemple
de sanctionner les familles défaillantes
très bien mais
la loi ci avait été abrogée par la
gauche nous avions reposé à ce
gouvernement
nous l'avions voté de la reprendre il
avait refusé qu'en sera-t-il demain
les courtepins souvent on les a proposés
à chaque fois il le gouvernement ou la
majorité présidentielle les a balayer
d'un revers de main donc ces
propositions là nous permettront de voir
si le projet gouvernemental est à la
hauteur ou c'est c'est simplement des
annonces si on est toujours dans le en
même temps voilà ce qui est fondamental
mais en conclusion je pense que on ne
pourra pas faire comme avant et si le
gouvernement reste dans le déni
il ne trouvera pas les chemins qui
permettront de traiter ces causes
racines qui sont vraiment à l'origine du
mal qu'on a connu dans des quartiers et
la prochaine fois bien sûr si c'est
cause ne sont pas traitées n'en doutez
pas un seul instant
la violence reviendra et la France
reboula
merci peu de choses à ajouter à ce qui a
été dit par par Eric et
Bruno si ce n'est qu'un redire la
gravité de ces événements et à quel
point ils ont révélé dans notre pays
finalement une
une faille d'une profondeur peut-être
soupçonnée une fracture supplémentaire
absolument terrible et qui est
inacceptable pour la communauté de la
communauté nationale que nous voulons
que nous voulons être que nous voulons
constituer ce qu'il y a d'inquiétant
c'est que les premiers éléments qui
apparaissent de la part de l'exécutif
semble révéler une forme de déni par
rapport à cette situation avec un
président de la République qui pour
l'instant a annoncé qu'un plan une loi
de reconstruction d'urgence dont on voit
mal la portée réelle
un ministre de l'Intérieur qui refuse de
reconnaître l'échec des politiques
d'intégration et d'assimilation dans
notre pays un garde des sceaux qui pour
l'instant ne semble pas disposés à
changer la moindre virgule de son texte
pénitentiaire d'orientation des moyens
de la justice qui est en cours de
discussion en ce moment même à
l'Assemblée nationale la situation que
nous avons vécu à l'évidence aux yeux de
nos concitoyens elle appelle un
changement de un changement de cap ce
changement de cap il doit avoir lieu
maintenant et ça ne semble-t-il pas
l'intention du gouvernement donc nos
propositions elles sont là pour apporter
matérialiser ses propositions de
changement de cap qui sont d'une extrême
nécessité la première des urgences c'est
évidemment de constater
l'effondrement de l'autorité de notre
pays lorsque le un des fils rouges une
évidence c'est que
les jeunes les très jeunes qui ont été
mis en cause dans les interpellations
sur les 3000 et quelques interpellations
la moyenne d'âge était de 17 ans
c'est une génération qui a vraiment un
sentiment total qui a intégré un
sentiment total d'appunité dans notre
pays donc la première réponse la réponse
la plus urgente la plus immédiate c'est
a besoin d'autorité qu'il faut restaurer
et c'est le sens des propositions qui
sont faites pour ça qu'on met
aujourd'hui
l'accent l'accent là-dessus
sur ce besoin d'autorité je voudrais
dire qu'il est nécessaire aussi pour
protéger cette jeunesse
moi je suis élu d'une ville Dreux qui a
été qui a connu des émeutes Dreux
Vernouillet les deux villes de la de la
commune de l'agglomération
ce qui me frappe finalement ce devoir
que s'il y a autant de mineurs en cause
parce que les mineurs sont trop souvent
instrumentalisées par des trafiquants
des trafiquants de drogue
si les mineurs ont pris l'habitude de
refuser
d'obtempérer ce qui est révélateur de ce
refus de toute autorité c'est parce
qu'ils sont en quelque sorte formés
formés pour ça utiliser pour ça que ces
mineurs sont trop souvent utilisés par
les trafiquants de drogue comme étant
leur guetteur comme étant les livreurs
et donc évidemment qu'il faut il faut
punir mais c'est aussi une façon de
protéger similaire on ne peut pas
accepter dans notre pays que des jeunes
s'enfoncent dans la délinquance
mobilisés utiliser manipuler par des
trafiquants de drogue
peut-être un dernier point en ajoutant
que ce projet s'il est très précis de
notre part il est pas il est pas nouveau
un certain nombre de propositions que
vous retrouverez ne sont que la reprise
de propositions qui ont été votées qui
ont été des réalités votées par la
droite lorsqu'elle était au pouvoir et
il faudrait pas rougir un grand auteur
mais notamment la proposition de loi ce
qu'on appelle laplci qui proposait de
suspendre les allocations familiales
pour les parents défaillants c'est une
mesure importante votée dans le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy qui a été
abrogé par François Hollande sur la
restauration de laquelle le gouvernement
les gouvernements d'Emmanuel Macron se
sont opposés à deux reprises les peines
plancher elle plancha avait été votée
par la droite elles ont été annulées par
Monsieur Hollande et Monsieur Macron
s'est gouvernements se sont opposés à la
restauration de ces peines plancher donc
je devrais peut-être une question mais
avec ces propositions ne cours après
personne
si ce n'est la restauration de
l'autorité qui a été incarnée dans ce
pays il y a une dizaine d'années et à
laquelle autorité à laquelle certains
ont fait le choix délibéré de tourner le
dos on voit le résultat
merci
Olivier et Bruno je vais
vous entrez dans le détail des textes et
des propositions sur les principaux
chapitres que
nous voulons traiter et qui constitue
pour nous comme l'a dit Bruno les
racines des des carreaux du chaos que
l'on a constaté nous nous adresserons
naturellement ce texte d'abord
premier sujet majeur celui de la réponse
pénale en matière de réponse pénale
nous portons une proposition claire que
nous défendrons dans le texte justice
qui est en cours de l'examen à
l'Assemblée c'est une capacité carcérale
minimale de 80 000 places de prison
dans cette capacité minimale nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de
place consacrée réservées aux mineurs
avec l'ouverture d'établissements
pénitentiaire pour mineur qui existe
aujourd'hui mais qui sont trop peu
nombreux nous souhaitons en matière de
capacité carcérale pour faire en sorte
que la réponse pénale qui s'exprime dans
une sanction pénale et notamment dans la
prison ferme qui ne doit plus être
l'exception comme nous l'entendons
depuis des années mais qui doit être un
outil qui n'est qui peut et qui doit
être utilisé dans les cas les plus
graves et nous itons également le nombre
le doublement du nombre de centres
éducatifs fermés pour les mineurs d'ici
nous souhaitons pour aller très
concrètement dans ce plan et nous
espérons que ces dispositifs seront
votés dans le texte justice nous
défendrons au niveau du groupe
républicain des amendements dans ce sens
et le Sénat sera mené à les soutenir
également dans le cadre de la commission
mixte paritaire nous voulons un plan
d'urgence pour la création de place de
prison notamment au travers de
structures modulaire qui pourrait être
installées aujourd'hui dans les
établissements pénitentiaires qui
existent et qui pourraient en quelques
semaines et au plus en quelques mois
augmenter de 4 à 5000 places le nombre
de places qui existent aujourd'hui nous
l'avions là aussi demandé depuis des
années nous réclamons la création d'un
secrétariat d'État auprès du garde des
sceaux à la construction de prison il
faut lever aussi tous les obstacles nous
serons amenés à voter une loi pour
favoriser la reconstruction des
bâtiments dégradés je pense qu'il faut
voter également des procédures pour
faciliter la création de nouvelles
structures pénitentiaires qui ne peuvent
subir aujourd'hui une multitude de
contraintes réglementaires
technocratique bureaucratique
en matière de réponse pénale Olivier
Marleix l'a rappelé nous voulons
réinstaller les peines plancher que qui
ont été supprimés par Monsieur Hollande
nous voulons les élargir les peines
plancher qui avait été votées sous le
gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy concerné
l'effet de récidive légal nous voulons
les étendre au fait de réitération c'est
à dire que se trouverait en situation
de pouvoir
subir l'effet d'une peine plancher toute
personne qui aura commis deux fois un
délit quel que soit la nature de ce
délit précédemment il fallait que ça
soit le même délice et la
caractéristique de la récidive légale
nous voulons pour les dépositaires pour
les victimes de violences alors qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
policiers nos gendarmes nos douaniers
nos agents pénitentiaires nos
sapeurs-pompiers nous voulons instaurer
des plaines planchers dès le premier des
noms voilà tu touches à une uniforme de
la République la sanction elle est
immédiate automatique et elle doit
conduire à la prison
nous voulons mettre en place un
dispositif qui rétablissent les courtes
peines qui sont aujourd'hui interdites
notamment les peines d'un mois nous
souhaitons que il y ait une réponse et
particulièrement pour les mineurs même
quelques jours de prison une semaine ça
se fait dans beaucoup de pays je pense
aux Pays-Bas notamment on a une logique
inverse chez nous qui installent une
forme d'impunité donc restaurant
réhabilitons et utilisons les courtes
peines
réponse pénale premier volet second
volet délinquance des mineurs sur la
délinquance des mineurs nous voulons
installer
comme pour les adultes des comparutions
immédiates je sais que dans des cadres
très particuliers avec le consentement
des parties
représentant l'ego du mineur exprimé par
son avocat elle pourrait avoir lieu mais
elle n'en en réalité quasiment sont
jamais appliquées nous voulons des
comparertions immédiates pour les
mineurs on a vu l'efficacité de la
réponse pénale lorsqu'elle s'appuie sur
la comparution immédiate avec en
quelques jours plusieurs centaines de
condamnations
et plusieurs centaines de condamnations
à de la prison ferme le message a été
entendu quand le message clair et ferme
il est reçu et c'est le meilleur moyen
pour retrouver le calme donc comparution
immédiate pour les mineurs
nous voulons la suppression de l'excuse
de minorité au-delà de 16 ans et
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale à 16
ans
nous voulons la remise en place
d'un dispositif de placement dans les
épisodes que j'avais fait voter en 2011
également qui permet de placer des
mineurs délinquants dans les épides les
établissements d'insertion de la défense
nationale qui avait permis de placer en
quelques mois plusieurs dizaines de
délinquants mineurs avec des outils de
réinsertion où on pouvait permettre à
ces jeunes de se réinsérer dans la vie
active de travailler de recevoir des
valeurs de porter un uniforme avec un
encadrement de type militaire ce
dispositif a aussi été abandonné par le
gouvernement socialiste il est issu de
la loi du 26 décembre 2011 elle est
celle-ci n'a pas été abrogée mais elle a
été coupée de ses sources de financement
nous voulons les rétablir
troisième volet qui se trouve aux
sources aux racines comme le dit Bruno
de des mots que nous avons constaté dont
nous avons souffert la responsabilité
parentale je l'ai déjà évoqué dans mon
propos liminaire nous voulons rendre les
parents des mineurs délinquants
pénalement responsables
en cas de manquement au respect
d'obligation judiciaire dont ferait
l'objet leurs enfants notamment par le
biais d'un contrat signé avec l'autorité
judiciaire nous voulons rétablir la loi
qui combattait l'absentéisme scolaire la
loi qui porte mon nom de 2010 qui
permettait dans un dispositif équilibré
gradué après un avertissement après un
suivi après la possibilité de mettre en
place des contrats de responsabilité
parentale de suspendre voire de
supprimer les allocations familiales
dans
le cas des mineurs délinquance le
premier sujet que j'évoquais il y a
aussi dans la loi ces deux textes ont
été déposés lundi à l'Assemblée
nationale la possibilité de supprimer
les allocations familiales quatrième
volet l'immigration et la nationalité
nous reprenons naturellement puisque
tout y est les deux textes que nous
avons d'ores et déjà déposées nous
soulignons à nouveau l'importance de les
inscrire à l'ordre du jour du Parlement
nous redisons alors que nous n'avons
reçu qu'une fin de non recevoir je sais
même pas si c'est une fin de
non-recevoir c'est une absence totale de
réponse de la part du président de la
République que nous voulons
l'inscription le débat de ces textes et
des propositions qu'elle contient pour
permettre notamment un plan
d'assimilation accélérée aux valeurs de
la République
pour permettre le rétablissement de la
double peine qui doit permettre
d'expulser systématiquement ceux qui se
sont rendus coupables d'attaques durant
ces derniers jours voilà un émeutier un
criminel qui a brûlé des bâtiments
publics
ceux qui ont eu une tentative qui ont
porté des tentatives d'assassinat contre
des élus contre des policiers des
pompiers s'ils sont étrangers non plus
rien à faire en France et la réponse
doit être automatique
prononcez automatique d'une occf assorti
d'une interdiction de territoire
français pour tout étranger coupable
d'un crime ou délit contre les biens ou
les personnes
de même nous disons très clairement que
nous ne voulons pas que l'acquisition de
la nationalité française par le droit du
sol soit autorisé pour tout mineur ayant
fait l'objet d'une condamnation qui sera
inscrite au casier judiciaire Un mineur
qui a commis un délit à fortiorer un
crime ne pourra pas devenir français à
18 ans s'il a été condamné dans le cadre
de ceux qui s'est déroulé nous voulons
la déchéance de la nationalité pour les
binationaux condamnés pour crime je dis
bien pour crime notamment dans le cadre
des incendies volontaires parce qu'un
incendie volontaire est un crime
passible de la cour d'assises
cinquième
volet
l'éducation
l'éducation le sens de la citoyenneté du
respect de l'autorité de la France de
l'insertion individuelle de chacun dans
un collectif qui nous oblige doit être
retrouvé à l'école nous voulons pour
cela faire en sorte que les jeunes
la jeunesse de France aime la France
qu'elle respecte les règles l'autorité
nous voulons pour cela instaurer le port
d'une tenue vestimentaire unique à
l'école au collège au lycée nous voulons
voir restaurer l'enseignement civique du
cours préparatoire au lycée nous voulons
refonder tout ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
pour réinstaller ce respect et cette
autorité nous voulons développer les
internats d'excellence il y en a 307
aujourd'hui ils doivent être quasiment
doublés et passer en tout cas à au moins
500 d'ici 2027 nous voulons ré-ouvrir
les établissements de réinsertion
scolaire qui a été créé par le
gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy qui
avait été là aussi supprimé nous voulons
aussi une puissante mesure d'insertion
de soutien mais individualisé on ne veut
plus de soutien à des territoires nous
vous ont des soutiens à des individus
selon leur parcours leur volonté leur
talent leur travail nous voulons partout
mettre en place un réseau de parrainage
des jeunes des jeunes talents
issus de milieux défavorisés subissant
des conditions sociales difficiles qui
seront accompagnés de même par des
hommes et des femmes expérimentés qui
ont dans leur domaine de compétences
réussie leur parcours professionnel
civique ou citoyen enfin et Bruno
Retailleau en a parlé nous voulons un
voler concernant les collectivités
locales en reprenant elle est déjà
déposée
la proposition de loi qui a été portée
par le Sénat par notamment par le
président de la commission des lois
François Noël buffet sur la protection
des élus nous voulons aggraver les
peines encourus pour des faits de
violence commises à l'encontre des élus
enfin de les aligner sur les peines
prévues pour les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique nous voulons une
peine d'intérêt général en cas d'un jour
public ce qu'elle est commise à
l'encontre de personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique dont les élus
nous voulons une circonstance aggravante
pour les cas de harcèlement notamment en
ligne des élus locaux nous voulons à
titre principal un caractère automatique
à la protection fonctionnelle des mers
des adjoints qui en font la demande pour
des faits commis dans l'exercice de leur
mandat
nous voulons une perte des droits
civiques pour tout infraction contre un
élu une personne détentrice de
l'autorité nous voulons que les mères
retrouvent la pleine et totale maîtrise
de l'attribution des logements sociaux
c'est Homère en tout cas nous le
souhaitons et nous le voulons que
désormais devraient revenir
l'attribution de tout logement social et
non plus à l'autorité administrative et
nous voulons enfin le renforcement des
pouvoirs de la police municipale qui a
joué et je veux le rappeler un rôle
essentiel dans la restauration de
l'ordre républicain et qui trop souvent
manquent de
capacités juridiques pour exercer
pleinement en coordination avec la
police nationale sous l'autorité des
procureurs de la République sa mission
voilà Mesdames Messieurs de façon
exhaustive mais vous aurez ce document
les propositions de notre famille
politique dans l'unité de nos groupes et
de notre partie pour porter une
véritable rupture en matière de réponse
pour restaurer l'ordre républicain on ne
peut plus se satisfaire de Placebo ce
qui s'est passé d'une extraordinaire
gravité qui menace la République nous
devons avoir conscience qu'il faut
changer de cadre nous devons imposer ce
changement de cadre au gouvernement et
l'appeler à entendre nos propositions et
à les appliquer dans les plus brefs
délais et notamment à les inscrire dès
cette semaine dans le texte justice qui
est débattu à l'Assemblée nationale pour
celle qui relèvent de la réponse pénale
que j'ai développé il y a quelques
instants je vous remercie
à votre disposition pour vos questions
pas de question
bonjour pour l'AFP vous avez fait état
de
pardon de différentes mesures qui à
l'évidence posent des problèmes
constitutionnelles je pense notamment à
la majorité pénale 16 ans avec la
suppression de l'excuse de minorité vous
avez aussi évoqué une responsabilité
pénale des parents en cas
d'inobservation des règles judiciaires
pour les enfants etc etc comment vous
pouvez contourner ou ses problèmes de
constitutionnalité par rapport à ses
propositions
l'essentiel et la casé intégralité des
propositions qui sont dans les textes
que nous allons déposer notamment celles
sur que vous évoquez sur la
responsabilité pénale parentale
s'inscrivent selon nous parfaitement
dans le cadre constitutionnel actuel
s'il faut des textes et notamment sur
l'extension des prérogatives des polices
municipales
puisque il y a eu plusieurs décisions du
Conseil constitutionnel dans ce sens
nous travaillerons à la mise en place
d'un texte constitutionnel de réforme de
la Constitution si cela est nécessaire
mais l'essentiel des propositions que
j'ai listées
relèvent quelquefois d'ailleurs de
dispositions réglementaires
relèvent d'une volonté politiquement
pour les places de prison
nous évoquons le texte parce que c'est
une loi de programmation mais elle
s'exprime aussi la volonté
elle relève de la volonté d'un exécutif
que nous appelons à l'action donc la
plupart des dispositions
il y a un texte constitutionnel celui
qui concerne les migrations nous l'avons
déjà déposé ce texte d'ailleurs permet
au travers son article 3 je crois
d'élargir le champ du référendum aussi
pour poser des questions et certaines de
ces questions je pense à un moment
pourraient être opportunément posé aux
Français pour lever certains obstacles
donc on a une boîte à outils qui est
parfaitement articulée
bonjour Julien Vanels pour BFM TV je
m'adresse à vous monsieur Retailleau
vous avez évoqué hier sur France Info en
évoquant donc les banlieues et la
violence je vous cite donc une
régression vers les origines ethniques
dans les banlieues ma question pourquoi
cette volonté de vous déporter
visiblement vers l'extrême droite en
utilisant des thèmes du RN il s'agit pas
de se déporter vers l'extrême droite je
voudrais
notamment pour les amateurs de football
ils ont souvent
pour préciser ma pensée en 2001 en 2001
a lieu le match France - Algérie
la Marseillaise est construite
des supporters envahissent le terrain et
à l'issue du match
Thierry Henry à cette phrase
nous avons joué à l'extérieur
pour moi et c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire
hier et je le rappelle solennellement et
fermement ce matin
le cœur de notre modèle républicain
français
c'est le dépassement des communautés
d'origine dans une seule communauté qui
dépasse toutes les autres communautés
particulières la communauté nationale
et on ne peut que regretter
et reprenez exactement ce que j'ai dit
hier pour éclairer mon propos
que malheureusement
des Français donc des jeunes qui ont
une carte d'identité française sont
tentés par un repli communautaire comme
un retour vers les origines alors que
souvent la première génération
leur idéal c'était d'intégrer de plein
pied
cette citoyenneté française ce modèle
républicain
posons-nous la question et précisément
la réponse c'est que si demain on veut
mieux assimiler mieux intégrés il faut
tarir les flux on ne pourra pas le faire
ça exige de nous un modèle un effort
extraordinaire et j'ai dit hier
que il y avait eu une responsabilité
qui aussi notre responsabilité c'est que
trop souvent à force de désigner la
France comme coupable de tout
à force de dire que la France était peu
aimable peu estimable ou qu'elle devait
être estimable pour peu qu'elle
reconnaisse sa culpabilité
on avait désigné la France comme une
communauté qui en réalité était un
contre modèle un contre-exemple comment
voulez-vous proposer un modèle comment
voulez-vous proposer à ces jeunes
d'adhérer à notre projet collectif si
vous désignez la France comme l'éternel
coupable Camus a une très belle phrase
là dessus
bien avant moi et si vous dites à ces
jeunes en réalité la France n'est pas
estimable elle n'est pas aimable bien
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi dans ce
problème là de l'assimilation et de
l'intégration je pense que
tarir les flux la maîtrise du chaos
migratoire c'est absolument essentiel
mais ça ne suffit pas
il y a un effort de l'école mais aussi
collectif pour que chacun d'entre nous
et tous les Français croient en la
France et quand on croira en la France
je pense que on attirera vers nous
des populations des groupes qui sont
tentés aujourd'hui par le séparatisme
écoutez moi je me situe pas par rapport
au RN je me situe par rapport à mes
convictions
que j'ai toujours dites
c'est ça ce phénomène là
et quand je disais tout à l'heure et je
parlais de racine de causes racines je
suis stupéfait que le gouvernement
écarte en réalité
le problème migratoire sans doute
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont un problème avec
le texte qui veulent présenter au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée nationale et que il
faut peut-être minorer
les effets les conséquences de cette
question pour s'excuser d'avance d'un
texte trop faible ou peut-être même de
pas du tout de texte
mais encore une fois le lien il est
évident j'ai pris le soin d'appeler des
maires
ville qui m'ont dit que ces quartiers
n'étaient pas n'importe quel quartier
que c'était des lieux où il y avait des
problèmes d'intégration et les Français
croyez moi j'attends les sondages à
venir pour savoir ce qu'ils en pensent
il faut pour traiter les choses pour
aller aux causes ouvrir les yeux parce
que sinon on n'est pas capable de le
faire
bonjour messieurs Pierrick Bono RFI je
vais compléter la question de ma concert
le gouvernement dément très clairement
tout lien avec l'immigration Gérald
Darmanin a encore précisé hier que
seulement 10% des auteurs de ces
violences
n'étaient pas français donc 90 % des
violences étaient pas français il a même
précisé hier que beaucoup des émeutiers
s'appelaient Kevin ou Matéo
voilà alors quelle est non mais quel est
votre réponse à ça et est-ce que le lien
que vous faites avec l'immigration n'est
pas exagérée tout simplement et on peut
toujours se masquer la réalité des
choses
PEGI disait il faut toujours
dire ce que l'on voit mais ce qui est
plus difficile voir ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui on peut rester dans une
forme de déni d'aveuglement
interroger les mers aller sur les
territoires où cela s'est passé déjà 10%
d'étrangers sur 4000 interpellations
c'est pour moi beaucoup c'est pas un
phénomène mineur d'étrangers
il faudra sans doute rajouter à ces
chiffres des binationaux
et nous avons la volonté de traiter ces
cas dans nos propositions
mais comment nier que dans ces quartiers
et si on nie cette réalité on y
apportera jamais de réponse efficace il
y a des problèmes liés à l'immigration
et à l'intégration notamment
de ceux qui sont devenus Français par
l'automaticité des droits du sol
et ce qui doit nous interroger comment
aujourd'hui
pouvons-nous accepter que des étrangers
qui sont venus en France dans les années
60-70 première génération
qui sont venus pour travailler souvent
seul ce soit parfaitement intégré aux
valeurs de la République et que ceux qui
les ont suivis qui sont devenus Français
ne nourrissent pas le même amour pour la
France pour le drapeau ça veut dire que
nous devons nous interroger sur les
causes de cet échec c'est ce que c'est
ce que dit Bruno Retailleau et arrêtons
avec les polémiques ridicules stériles
l'appel systématique à l'extrême droite
voilà les Français supportent plus
discours
il subissent au quotidien une réalité
ils veulent des réponses voilà donc on
peut nier le problème comme le fait
monsieur Darmanin mais si on le nie
aujourd'hui il sera beaucoup beaucoup
plus grave encore demain voilà les
Français le savent qui étaient au cœur
des émeutes voilà pas besoin de faire
appel à des prénoms
il le savent voilà les maires le savent
et ils connaissent les difficultés donc
arrêtons de d'avoir un peu cette posture
de de ce
type proverbe chinois qui disait quand
le sage regarde la lune l'imbécile
regarde le doigt voilà on est là depuis
des décennies
nous on restera pas dans le déni
je voudrais dire un mot sur ce sujet qui
me
touche beaucoup moi je suis je voulais
dire député de Dreux à Dreux plus de la
moitié de la population à une histoire
familiale liée liée à l'immigration
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit se développer
dans certains de nos quartiers et je
passe beaucoup de temps je la moitié de
ma semaine à recevoir des habitants de
ces quartiers on voit se développer dans
les jeunes générations un réflexe du E
et nous un réflexe du E et nous
c'est c'est une perspective qui est
insupportable si on a cette ambition
d'être une communauté nationale
pour reprendre les mots du président
Chirac moi je suis très à l'aise avec
cette idée qui est évidemment tout le
monde est enfant de la République mais
qu'aujourd'hui des enfants de la
République ne se sentent pas français ne
se sentent pas français se désigne
autrement parfois
c'est une perspective qui est
inacceptable et la seule façon de
réparer ce lien c'est déjà d'admettre le
constat de ne pas être dans le déni et
donc je crois que le gouvernement que
met une erreur grave monsieur Darmanin
en particulier dans ce déni aujourd'hui
notre communauté nationale est en danger
et si on veut
si on veut pas renoncer à ce rêve d'être
une nation et bien il faut en faire le
constat et se donner les moyens de
réparer cette communauté nationale
bonjour Alexandre suzer du Parisien vous
avez cité Pascal tout à l'heure en
disant que la justice sans la force est
impuissante la force sans la justice et
tyrannique les mesures sur la force sont
assez évidentes dans ce que vous avez
développé en revanche vous n'avez pas du
tout évoqué des questions de justice
sociale de politique de la ville de
chômage d'emploi est-ce que ces aspects
là sont complètement en dehors de votre
champ de réflexion par rapport à ce qui
se passe dans les quartiers
les réponses que nous voulons apporter
sont des réponses qui permettent de
rétablir l'ordre républicain c'est le
titre de notre plan c'est notre objectif
nous ne faisons pas de lien
parce que nous considérons que ce lien
il est indigne infamant entre la
situation sociale et le respect des lois
de la République ça c'est pour Madame
Rousseau
et peut-être pour Monsieur Mélenchon
voilà c'est pas parce qu'on est en
difficulté sociale
qu'il y a une excuse à piller voler
casser incendie ça c'est un discours que
nous récusons que nous condamnons qui
est honteux et ce qui me permet de
redire que nous avons été dans ces
moments extraordinairement difficiles où
la République avait signé face à des
gens qui ont voulu mettre en péril des
piliers de la République et notamment
derrière Monsieur Mélenchon et Madame
Rousseau
ça aurait pu s'adresser au président
moi m'a porté toujours ouverte
on est alors au Sénat on est dans la
majorité sénatoriale on est dans
l'opposition présidentielle mais moi je
considère que quand on est député
sénateur président de parti et quand on
est dans l'opposition nationale ce que
l'on veut d'abord c'est pas par réflexe
pavlovien
politicien s'opposer à un président
République ou une chef de gouvernement
on essaie de faire le bien du pays
et par conséquent et quand je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure parce que c'est ce qu'on
a fait sur les migration la proposition
les propositions que nous avons fait sur
l'immigration ont eu
une première vertu c'est que le
gouvernement doit se situer par rapport
très concrètement à nos propositions et
quand je disais tout à l'heure que j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'annonces et bien très
bien ok on va y compris sur l'autorité
parentale y compris sur la justice des
mineurs très bien on fait ses
propositions comment ce que le
gouvernement va se situer par rapport à
ses propositions tant qu'on est dans les
grands discours les grands effets
d'annonce et Dieu sait s'il présente
République et quasiment dépassable en la
matière et en tout cas je sais pas moi
qui souhaite aller au-delà de ma
condition de ce point de vue là dans le
discours mais je pense que ces actes là
qui sont encore une fois tout comme ce
que l'on a fait sur l'immigration une
vraie rupture on va bien voir comment le
gouvernement
si comment dire répond
c'est ça qui est fondamental est-ce que
est-ce que j'ai répondu à votre question
ou est-ce que c'est
ah bah écoutez
notre porte elle est ouverte elle est
ouverte notre porte je pense que
nous avions d'ailleurs signé un consigne
un courrier au président de la
République pour pouvoir nous exprimer
pour pouvoir détailler les propositions
et surtout l'esprit du texte les deux
textes que nous avions mis sur la table
sur l'immigration pour l'instant on n'a
pas eu de réponse
mais bien sûr que notre porte est
ouverte et si la discussion moi je veux
je veux bien du pays voilà il croyez-moi
ce que je crains le plus c'est qu'on
fasse comme avant que après finalement
l'actualité médiatique on passe à autre
chose et que rien de fondamental ne soit
traité sur le fond
bonjour Victor boiteux libération
concernant la déchéance de nationalité
le rassemblement national estime que
c'est de la surenchère vous vous en
faites un symbole est-ce que vous
pourriez un petit peu préciser la portée
de cette mesure et autres petites
questions sur l'envoie qui était en
déplacement cette semaine à Roanne
auprès des forces de l'ordre il n'a pas
établi publiquement de lien entre les
émeutes et les migration est-ce que lui
aussi est dans une forme de déni merci
votre question s'inscrit parfaitement
dans la ligne idéologique de votre
journal et je salue votre cohérence
la déchéance de la nationalité elle
porte pour les binationaux qui ont été
condamnés pour crime voilà donc c'est
une réponse
et nous là elle est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs autorisée dans la loi en cas
d'atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation quand on
incendie un bâtiment public une école
lorsque l'on s'attaque au domicile d'un
maire
tels que ce fut le cas pour Vincent Jean
Brun et sa famille auquel je veux redire
mon soutien mon estime si les auteurs de
ces crimes devaient être je l'ignore
naturellement des étrangers
ils devraient être expulsé s'il devait
être des Français en situation de
binationalité et bien oui nous
utiliserons cette arme Laurent Wauquiez
a dit clairement les choses je crois
qu'il a dit aussi dans une interview il
était aux côtés des forces de l'ordre
et il a dit avec clarté sa position sur
le pays je suis pas certain que vous
soyez le meilleur exégète de la pensée
de Laurent Wauquiez
merci une question ici marie-molette
pour RTL j'avais une question sur les
propos de votre collègue Jacqueline au
stage brignaud hier soir lors de
l'audition de Géral de Darmanin elle a
demandé des chiffres je la cite sur ces
mots issus de l'immigration qui ont
cassé et qui ont pillé est-ce que vous
vous demandez des esthétiques des
statistiques qu'on appelle ethniques sur
sur les personnes qui ont cassé et pillé
les statistiques ethniques aujourd'hui
n'existent pas personnellement je le
déplore ils existent dans beaucoup de
pays dans la plupart des pays de l'Union
européenne ça sera ça sera un débat
c'est un outil j'étais au Danemark il y
a quelques semaines c'est un outil qui
est totalement banalisé c'est un outil
de politique publique d'intégration
aussi parce que comment mesurer
dans un quartier
la question de l'amélioration de
l'intégration puisque je réponds je
profite pour rajouter compléter à la
question de Monsieur suzer on a des
mesures aussi pour casser les ghettos
dans les quartiers et notamment
en ayant pas simplement une réponse sur
le bâti parce que il faut bien mesurer
que cette réponse à la quand même
beaucoup échoué mais à travers un suivi
de la personne quand nous prenons des
internats d'excellence quand nous
voulons des parcours de pour les jeunes
talents qui sont suivis par des personne
qui peuvent être des exemples pour eux
des espèces de tuteurs qui
accompagneraient ça c'est une politique
individualisée c'est pas repeindre des
quartiers qui sont aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup livrés aux mains des dealers et
pas évoqué la question de la drogue qui
est souvent sous-jacente à ces tensions
à ces violents nous porterons un plan
antidrogue au niveau des républicains
donc voilà aujourd'hui il y a un état du
droit on peut pas l'appliquer
personnellement je le je le déplore
voilà je le déplore mais arrêtons d'être
dans une forme de déni peut-être et ça
sera mon mot de la fin que Monsieur
Darmanin va nous refaire le coup des
supporters anglais dans les émeutes
peut-être qu'ils ont aimé tellement le
Stade de France qui sont revenus de
façon festive dans les soirées de la
semaine dernière voilà soyons à un
moment sérieux responsable et regardons
la vérité elle est suffisamment grave
pour ne pas l'ignorer merci beaucoup